ميل، نحن فخورون حقًا ومن دواعي
سروري وجودك هنا معنا،
أريد فقط أن أبدأ بإعادتك إلى
أيام تشيلسي، فقط أريدك أن تتذكر
المباراة التي لا تنسى التي لعبتها مع
البلوز خلال فترة وجودك مع ستانفورد
بريدج جيدًا  من الواضح أن الجميع يعرف
أن أكثر مباراة أفتخر بها أو
أفضل مباراة لي يقولها الجميع هي
نهائي دوري أبطال أوروبا، وهو عندما
فزنا بدوري أبطال أوروبا، لذلك بالنسبة لي،
كانت تلك مباراة خاصة في ليلة معينة، كما
تعلمون، الفوز أخيرًا
كان دوري أبطال أوروبا مع تشيلسي
أمرًا مميزًا جدًا لأنك تعلم أننا كنا نعلم أن
هذه كانت إلى حد كبير
فرصتنا الأخيرة للتمكن من الفوز، كما تعلم،
وكان الفوز بعد ذلك أمرًا
مميزًا جدًا وبالنسبة لي
شخصيًا أن أحصل على مثل هذا
أداء رائع رائع كما تعلم
كان أه شيئًا مميزًا حقًا بالنسبة
لي لذلك أقول دائمًا نهائي دوري أبطال أوروبا
هل فقدت الأمل في تلك المباراة
مثل أليانز أرينا إنه رقم 10 بالنسبة
لبايرن هل تفقد الأمل كما هو الحال في مرحلة معينة بالطبع
حتى قبل  لقد كنا
مثل يا واو، هذا هو بايرن، أنت تعلم أن
لديهم لعبًا رائعًا، كما تعلم أن B شير
توني كروز لامب، أه روبن ريبيري، أنت تعلم أنه
كان لديهم لاعبين رائعين وكان لدينا
الكثير من اللاعبين الموقوفين أو المصابين الذين
لم يلعبوا المباراة أيضًا  لذلك كنا نقول
أن هذه ستكون مباراة صعبة
بالنسبة لنا، ولكن بعد ذلك عندما
بدأت المباراة اعتقدنا أننا بخير في
المباراة، كما تعلم أننا نحاول أن نرى كيف
يمكننا الحصول على فرصة أو اثنتين ونأمل
خذه وبعد ذلك يمكننا الدفاع ولكن بعد ذلك
سجلوا الهدف، اعتقدنا أن آه، ها نحن
نعود مرة أخرى، سنخسر
نهائيًا آخر لدوري أبطال أوروبا، ولكن بعد ذلك
بالطبع عندما يكون لديك شخص معين
يسمى الدربا في فريقك عندما يتعلق الأمر بـ
المباريات الكبيرة كما تعلمون، وذلك عندما
ينهض، كما تعلمون، بالنسبة
لنا أن يسجل هذا الهدف الكبير،
لم يكن ذلك مفاجأة لأنك تعلم أن هذا ما
يفعله، وعليه أن يفعل ذلك
ثم يأخذنا إلى ركلة جزاء  سددها
ثم سجل ركلة الجزاء الأخيرة أيضًا، لقد
كُتب في النجوم أن
هذه هي الطريقة التي ستنتهي بها مسيرة تشيلسي المهنية
بالتأكيد أه ولكن نعم، يا لها من
ليلة مميزة جدًا بالنسبة
لنا، لقد كافح تشيلسي كثيرًا
لأكون صادقًا  للفوز بدوري أبطال أوروبا
قبل ثلاث سنوات، كنت تلعب
في ملعب ستانفورد بريدج ضد برشلونة،
نعم وتلك المباراة انتهت بالتعادل 1-1،
وسجل إنيستا الهدف القاتل في
نهاية تلك المباراة، أخبرني
المزيد عن المباراة التالية  في تلك المباراة،
هل شعرت أن تشيلسي تعرض للسرقة، هل
تشعر أنهم كانوا يعرفون أنهم
يستحقون الفوز بتلك المباراة، ولكن
كان هناك شيء غير عادل يحدث في تلك
المباراة، أعتقد أنه من الواضح أنه عندما تنظر إلى
المباراة، فإن كل من كان في المباراة
يعرف ذلك  كان هناك عدد قليل من
القرارات التي لم تسر في صالحنا إذا
سارت في صالحنا في تلك الليلة، أعتقد أنها
كانت ستكون قصة مختلفة كنا
سنفوز بالمباراة ولكن من الواضح أن
تلك القرارات لم تسير في صالحنا
لسبب ما
لم يعطنا الحكم القرارات وليس
جميعها ولكنني اعتقدت أنه ربما كان يجب منح واحد أو اثنين
أه ولكن بعد ذلك من
الواضح أنه يغير سيناريو
المباراة بالكامل أه من الواضح أن إنيستا سجل ثم سجل
هدفًا قاتلًا يا أخي أه  وبعد ذلك
خسرنا المباراة،
كانت المباراة جنونية، كما تعلم، فقد الكثير من
اللاعبين أعصابهم، فقدوا
عواطفهم الرائعة، كما تعلم، كان يحلق
عاليًا، كما تعلم، فقد فقد
عقله، وأنت تعلم أننا كنا نحن  كل ذلك
محبط للغاية لأننا علمنا أننا
لعبنا بشكل جيد حقًا وكان يجب أن
نحصل على شيء من المباراة
لم نحصل عليه والإحباط
من عدم الفوز مرة أخرى والفوز
بدوري أبطال أوروبا مرة أخرى في ذلك العام كان
شيئًا تعلم أنه كان أنت  من
الواضح أننا نعلم أن
اللاعبين يتقدمون في السن، وبالتالي فإن
الضغط أكبر بكثير، ثم
اعتقدنا أنه لا بأس بهذه المباراة على الأقل كان
ينبغي علينا أن نخوضها،
لذا نعم كان هذا هو الإحباط
بعد المباراة، لقد كنا جميعًا
محبط للغاية من الفستان
محبط للغاية، لذا نعم، علمنا أنه
يتعين علينا الذهاب مرة أخرى في العام التالي، وكانت تلك هي
العقلية، حسنًا، فلنعد مرة أخرى
في العام التالي، ولهذا السبب فزنا أخيرًا
بدوري أبطال أوروبا وهو ما
كان بمثابة  لحظة فخر للعلاقات العامة بالنسبة
للنادي، هذه قصة رائعة ومثيرة للاهتمام
بصراحة، لكي يتم إخبارنا دائمًا
عن كيفية فوز تشيلسي
بدوري أبطال أوروبا، قبل عامين من عام 2009،
كان هناك رجل يُدعى جوزيه مورينيو
وهو أحد أفضل المدربين على الإطلاق
وأعتقد أنه  كان هو الشخص الذي قام بتغيير
مركزك من c إلى CDM، لذا ما هي
اللحظة الأكثر خصوصية التي عشتها مع
جوزيه في ستانفورد
بريدج أوه، حسنًا، اللحظات الخاصة من
الواضح أنها مع جوزيه، كما تعلم،
هناك دائمًا لحظات كثيرة
مع جوزيه هناك  لم تمر لحظة مع
خوسيه أبدًا، ولهذا السبب فهو رئيس، اه، إنه
رئيس، اه، أنت تعلم أن لديه هذا اه هذا
الحضور عنه، هذه الغطرسة
عنه اه هذا اه BR هذه
قسوة تجاهه تعلم أنه يجب عليك
الفوز، لديك  لكي تؤدي أداءً أفضل،
عليك أن تعلم أنه يمكنك القيام بعمل أفضل،
خذ نفسك إلى هذا المستوى حيث يعلم أنه
يمكنك اللعب بشكل أفضل، ويمكنك
الأداء بشكل أفضل، وإذا لم تفعل ذلك، فسيكون
أول من يخبرك بأنه
سيكون أول من يفعل ذلك.  تأكد من أنه
يجد طريقة للتأكد من حصوله على ذلك
منك، سواء كنت لا تتحدث إليك، أو كنت
قاسيًا للغاية بشأن ذلك، فسوف
يجد طريقة للتواصل
معك للحصول على الأفضل لأنه
يعلم أنه يمكنك فعل ذلك، وهو يعلم أنه يمكنك فعل
ذلك، وعليك أن تبرزه، لذلك بالنسبة لي،
نعم، أعتقد أن معظمه
هو المحادثة التي أجريناها
في غرفة تبديل الملابس في كما تعلم
في  الشوط الثاني، إذا كنا نخسر
مباراة في الشوط الأول ثم
دخل ثم هاجم الجميع
وقتل الجميع ثم عدنا
للخارج ثم فزنا بالمباراة،
فهناك الكثير من اللحظات مع جوزيف ولكن
نعم  خاص جدًا، خاص جدًا، لقد
تحدثت عن كيف جعل جوزيه محمد
صلاح يبكي ذات مرة، لذا فإن ما حدث في
تلك الحادثة تعلم أنه مجرد
جزء مما يفعله جوزيه، وهو مجرد
جزء من كيفية حصوله على أفضل النتائج من
اللاعبين.  أه مو لم يكن
يقدم أفضل مباراة وهو ما تعلم
أنه لم يكن يتمتع بأفضل مسيرة مهنية
في تشيلسي، لذلك لم يكن يقدم
أفضل مباراة في ذلك اليوم ومن الواضح أن
جوزيه ذهب باليستيًا وغضب منه وأنت
تعرف ومن ثم تعلم أن مو مو مو
كان شابًا في ذلك الوقت ومن ثم
تعلم عاطفيًا أيضًا ومن ثم تعلم أنه
من الواضح أن هناك القليل من الدموع هنا وهناك
وتعلم أنه ربما شعر أنك تعلم
أنه لم يكن اللاعب الوحيد الذي كان كذلك  لا
يلعب بشكل جيد ولكن هذا هو
جوزيه الذي يحاول الحصول على أفضل ما في
مو لأنه كان يعلم أن مو يمكنه القيام بعمل أفضل
ومن الواضح أن مو لم يتعامل مع الأمر جيدًا وأنت
تعلم أنك تعرف بعض المستويات هنا
وهناك ولكن بعد ذلك أم نعم  لكنني أعتقد أن
هذا ربما هو الشيء الذي عندما
أنظر إلى مصلى اليوم أعتقد أن تلك
المواقف ساعدته اليوم على النمو
ويصبح أنت تنظر إليه الآن يبدو
أنه يبدو عقليًا إنه لا يبدو
جسديًا فقط عندما تنظر إليه الآن
عقليًا  إنه يبدو أقوى، يبدو
أقوى وأنا سعيد جدًا برؤيته
يؤدي بالطريقة التي يؤدي بها
ويصبح النجم الذي هو عليه اليوم. الأمر
ليس مو فقط، بل كيفن دي بروين في
نفس الوقت، فهم أفضل اللاعبين
الآن في العالم.  عندما أشاهد
كيفن دي بري يلعب معي، يسعدني أن
أشاهده وهو يلعب بالطريقة التي يمرر بها
الكرة بالطريقة التي
يلعب بها أحد أفضل اللاعبين
حاليًا في الدوري الإنجليزي الممتاز، دعني
آخذك هنا إلى المنطقة قبل أه الآن أنت
أعلم أن هناك أشياء تحدث في
المملكة العربية السعودية، فهم يجلبون
نجومًا عظماء ولاعبين كبارًا يأتون إلى هنا إلى
المنطقة، لذلك قلت إنني كنت أستعد
للمقابلة ورأيت مثل بعض
الملاحظات أه التي قلتها إن هازارد
عُرض عليه حوالي 50 مليونًا  يورو من
نادي سعودي شيء من هذا القبيل حسنًا، هل
لديك أي تفاصيل حول ذلك أم لا أنا أنا أنا
متأكد تمامًا أنني لم أقل 50
مليونًا أعتقد أن محادثتي معه
كانت أنه عُرض عليه مبلغ يقارب
المليون أو شيء من هذا القبيل
أسبوع أو بضعة أسابيع لا أعرف،
لكني أجريت محادثة معه،
كل ما قاله لي هو
أنني لا أحتاج حقًا إلى المال،
أريد أن أكون في مكان ما حيث سأكون سعيدًا
مع عائلتي التي أريدها.  أن أكون سعيدًا مع
عائلتي بالنسبة لي، هذا هو
أهم شيء الآن لدي ما يكفي من
المال ولا أحتاج للذهاب إلى مكان
حيث لن أكون سعيدًا،
أريد أن أكون حيث سأكون سعيدًا إذا  إنها
كرة القدم لأنه من الواضح أنه
يريد التأكد من أن عائلته
ستكون سعيدة، لذلك ربما لم يشعر أن
الذهاب إلى السعودية سيكون
شيئًا يريد القيام به وبعد ذلك
وبعد ذلك نعم وقال
الآن أطفالي سعداء في مدريد، فنحن نعيش
في مدريد، وهم يذهبون إلى المدرسة في مدريد
ولا أريد إخراجهم من
مدريد وأقول حسنًا، فلنعيش في
السعودية لأنك تعلم أنهم أطفال
لديهم أصدقاء تعرفهم.  لذلك أنا
أفهم تمامًا من أين
أتى، وأعتقد أنه
شعر أن العائلة هي المقام الأول،
وبعد ذلك عندما تصل إلى هذا العمر، فإن
العائلة هي كل شيء إذا كنت لاعبًا
الآن ولم تتقاعد بعد
ولديك عرض من
نادي سعودي، دعنا نقول هل تقبل ذلك، هل
تقبله، لست في هذا
الوضع الآن،
تلك القرارات لا أستطيع اتخاذها
بعد الآن، لذا نعم اه إذا كنت لا أزال
ألعب اه وبعد ذلك  لقد جاء نعم،
ربما سأنظر في الأمر وأتحدث
مع عائلتي وأصدقائي وأرى ما
نقرره، ربما لن يكون
قراري وحدي، لذا نعم وبالنسبة لي،
دعنا نقول إنني محظوظ لأنني لست في ذلك
موقف اتخاذ القرار لاتخاذ هذا القرار
الآن سأنتهي بطرح
السؤال الذي أطرحه دائمًا على نفسي،
نعم، كان هناك العديد من اللاعبين الأفارقة
الذين قدموا أداءً رائعًا وفازوا
بدوري أبطال أوروبا والذين قدموا أداءً
جيدًا حقًا في أوروبا ولكن حتى الآن
لدينا لاعب أفريقي واحد فقط فاز
بالبلاندور، وهو جورج وايا في عام 1995، لماذا
تعتقد أن هذا
يحدث بشكل جيد، أعني أنه صعب، إنه أمر
صعب حقًا، من الواضح أنني أعتقد أننا
هذا العام، نحن نعلم أننا اقتربنا
قليلاً من الفوز بشكل واضح.  كما تعلمون أن
مجيئ ثمانية ثمانية هو أمر
رائع للغاية، كما تعلمون، أن يكون مثل هذا
اللاعب الشاب قادرًا على تحقيق
شيء كهذا، إنه أمر
رائع للغاية، كما تعلم أنه من
الرائع الفوز بالبالاندور جيدًا،
أعتقد أنه خلال الـ 15 عامًا الماضية، دعنا نقول  15 عامًا
أو نحو ذلك يجب أن يكونا هذين الاثنين، يجب أن
يكونا هذين الاثنين اللذين دفعا بعضهما
البعض، يجب أن يكون إما ميسي أو
رونالدو، كما تعلم لقد قلت دائمًا
وأقول مرة أخرى بالنسبة لي، أعتقد أن ميسي بالنسبة لي هو
الأفضل  أعظم لاعب لعب
اللعبة لقد حقق رونالدو الكثير ولا آخذ أي
شيء من كريستيانو رونالدو لقد
قام بعمل جيد بشكل مذهل لنفسه آه
رجل رائع لاعب رائع ليس لدي
أي شيء ضده أم آه
من العمل الشاق الذي بذله، إنه
كذلك  من الجميل أن ترى شخصًا يبذل الكثير من
العمل الشاق ويحقق الكثير وما تم
تحقيقه ويصبح ما هو عليه اليوم
مصدر إلهام للعديد من
اللاعبين الشباب الشباب أن الموهبة ليست
كافية فقط ولكن لديك هذا الرجل الذي هو
Talent H والذي بطبيعة الحال  موهوب وموهوب
ويفعل أشياء
لم أفعلها ولا أستطيع أن أرى أي شخص يكررها في
ملعب كرة القدم وهو ليونا
ميسي، لذلك بالنسبة لي في رأيي الذي
قلته مرارًا وتكرارًا أنه في
رأيي كل شخص لديه رأيه
كل شخص لديه خياره في
رأيي، أعتقد دائمًا أن ميسي هو أنا
لم أر لاعب كرة قدم مثله أبدًا لأنني
لعبت ضد الاثنين وأعرف كيف
لعب كلاهما، لذا بالنسبة لي سأذهب دائمًا مع
ميسي، شكرًا جزيلاً لك.
نقدر ذلك شكرا لك